hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website comm and today we're
looking at day number five from the 2017
champions showdown if you're not
familiar with the structure of this
tournament there's eight of the top
players in the world each of those
players is matched up against one
individual and they play heads up and
they play 30 games over a four day span
it's a lot of blitz and rapid styles you
can imagine playing 30 games but these
games are intense you see some
strategies you normally don't see six of
those competitors they started early I
would consider early and they played
four days straight Magnus Kraus and
England the last matchup they started on
everyone else's day three so that the
last two days would only be Magnus
Carlsen the world champion and at Delian
now Dingling if you're not too familiar
he's the top Chinese Grandmaster he's
one of the eight competitors that will
be fighting in and he candidates
tournament next year the winner of the
Canada's tournament goes on to face
Magnus Carlsen at the end of next year
for the World Championship he got there
who's one of the top two finishers in
the chess World Cup 2017 along with
Levon Aronian so this could actually be
a preview of the World Championship next
year that will have a much different
time control in this format today we're
on the 10-minute blitz portion and we're
gonna be playing eight games today
between Magnus Carlsen and ding Lehrer
now the first two days that they played
managed Carlsen they kind of had his way
with being there and he went up a game
in a day number one they only played
four games and then yesterday he went up
three games now today in day number
three for these competitors day 5 for
the entire tournament
ding leerin won Game one with the black
pieces and he's playing with the white
pieces in game number two looking to
come back and really let his opponent
know that he is one of the top chess
players in the world so ding lien starts
out with a pawn to f3 pawn at d5 pawn g3
pawn g6 Bishop g2 fiend keto going on at
the Kings side of the board bishop
seven pawn at d4 and then after pawns c6
cast on the kingside Knight to f6 so
this is sort of a fee in keto grünfeld
defense we see the grünfeld defense
quite often especially for Magnus
crossing but we usually don't see it
with White's playing being keto on the
kingside not a normal setup you know we
used to see this from Karpov back in the
day Kasparov he played pretty much every
opening so he had some great success
with this but just not something we see
that often but as we've seen so far in
the champion showdown we're seeing all
sorts of openings trying to catch their
opponent off guard you only have ten
minutes
so any small advantage that you can use
you're pretty much bringing it out right
now
why continues with pawns who be three
casts on the King side Bishop to b2 so
if he ain't kiddo both sides of the
board also something we don't see too
often maybe trying to confuse Magnus
Carlsen Magnus is gonna continue with
normal development Bishop to f5 sort of
that Slav defense where he can play pawn
to e6 solidifies pawn chain but he does
have his light to her bishop outside his
pawn chain already pawn up to c4
threatening on the Queen side of the
board at Knight to d7 defending this
square here on f6 also if he wants to
bring it to b6 fairly common start to
attack the Queen side the board as well
pawn to e3 and then Knight down here to
e4 so couple options kind of expected
him just to play this pawn to e6 to
solidify pawn chain but decides and said
hey there's nothing really stopping my
knight right here
many times the knight will already be
here on a d2 white might already have
his queen a c2 as well he doesn't really
have those threats so he decides it's a
good opportunity to go ahead and play
Knight to e4 in the center of the board
Knight comes back d2 says yeah let's go
in exchange if you want to Knight to f6
defending this really likes the square
so says hey let's let's go to exchange
if you want to Knight takes bishop
retakes because he's fine if and this
puts your spot being Liam wants to
recapture it's gonna be a lot tougher
for white to kick off this Knight here
can apply a lot of pressure to his
opponent so
and here we don't see bingler in
exchange he decides to instead play
Bishop here to h3 and now Queen to b6
not too much he can do on the King side
of the board recognizes that the Queen
sides probably the place that he wants
to go to and this also allows him to add
a little bit more pressure on this pawn
on d4 and this square as a whole once
his knight moves his Bishop will also be
lining up that he can push forward with
pawn to c5 attack that square as well
pawn to f3 forcing the bishop to move it
can't really come back here to f5 it's
definitely not going to take here so
really just has to end up exchanging on
B one after the Rookery captures pawn to
e6 solidifying the pawn chain so
Dingling does have the bishop pair but
bishops usually tend to do well on a
open board state meaning there's not a
lot of pawns in the center of the board
so all things considered I say it's
pretty much even there's not a lot of
King's safety for White's perspective
his pawns are pushed a little bit
forward but he does have a solid a solid
base right here it's gonna be tough for
Magnus Carlsen to really break through
Magnus Carlsen also has a good pawn
structure neither side really has an
initiative really just comes down to
time control is anyone gonna make a
mistake or try to find a small advantage
to push through on their opponent ding
they're in plays Queen to d3 just
centralizing rook e8 getting involved
into the board pawn c5 pushes forward
gained space from White Queen back to c7
pawn to e4 started pushed in the stern
of the board pawn b6 attacking on the
Queen side both sides recognizing what
they need to do white needs to continue
to push for choke his opponent from
moves and from blacks perspective
Magnus really needs to just blow up the
Queen side of the board pawn to e5
forcing the knight come comes back here
to d7 pawn b4 pawn a5 and so there's
there's no real way especially with the
pawns just blocked in the center of the
board
this Knights not gonna be going anywhere
for a while you'll see Magnus Carlsen
start to load up on the Queen side of
the board pawn to a3 rook to b8 swing it
over to the queen side as expect
Bishop c3 Bishop comes back here to FA
this bishops not doing a whole lot but
he recognizes there could be some
exchanges on board and also always have
to keep in mind that this pawn did move
to f3 and that was a little bit earlier
on but it does you know something for us
to think about as if there is an
exchange on board you could always have
a bishop that checks this King here on
g1 forces it to move could gain some
tempo later on in the game rook here to
a c1 pawn takes pawn recaptures we
started seeing exchange on the board and
now look to a3 and this is where things
get get kind of crazy cuz Magnus Carlsen
he's he's kind of struck first as far as
getting in his opponent's territory and
how does White respond here well he has
a few options really the best strategy
would play rook to a1 and then you know
rook down here b3 trying to double up
but then you see an exchange Rick here
to a-1 says hey if you want exchange
that's fine with me now the board
starting to open up a little bit but he
has the bishop pair all in all I think
this is gonna be a good board state for
whites but in the game he decides to
play Bishop to f1 and you know as you
kind of look at this it doesn't look too
bad but Magnus Carlsen actually sees
what we talked about just a minute ago
and that is he can give up his night
here on c5 and after the pawn recaptures
Bishop recaptures Bishop takes e5 check
now he has to pass pawns in the center
of the board he did give up his knight
but he has a huge attack after this King
to h1 and now I push this forward pawn
d4 forcing the bishop to move there's an
in-between move sometimes you always
look for ways to have a in-between move
the opponent has to respond to this is
check after that's a queen to b8 and
then okay something else has to get hey
if you want to take my bishop I'll take
your Bishop as well so we see the rook
take on c3 first all these moves kind of
in between before that pawn were to take
so rook takes on c3 pawn just gonna
capture now here on a c3 and now in this
position what would you do
if your whites perspective he has a
couple options as far as if you want to
take material or if he wants to try
something else but curious from your
perspective feel free to pause that
analyze the game but what would you do
in this position if you were ding lien
now honestly what he probably should
have done is take right here on c3 and
with just a few seconds it's tough to
analyze just how deadly a passed pawn
can be when it comes that far up the
board he decided to go ahead and take
this bishop here on c5 you know it's
more material but the problem is Queen
down here to b1 is deadly now from here
he has to stop Queen to f1 that's one of
the biggest hurdles that he has to worry
about but he also has to worry about the
pollen coming down here to see - and it
doesn't really matter how he stops this
if he plays Queen to see for stopping
this Bishop here on f1 okay well then
just pawn to c2 he he also just can't
take this material here because that's
gonna be checkmate that's the worst case
scenario he also can't play Queen to g1
because just that continue push down
here pawn to c2 in the game he played
King to g2 none of it really matters
pawn - see - and then Queen up here to
d6 Queen to d1 says hey let's go in
exchange on board I'll just recapture
with my pawn I'll get a queen on board
this will be extremely good for me
there's no way I can lose this Dingling
decides after Queen d1 Bishop up here d3
he needs to stop this Queen threat he
wants to come up here Queen to d8 and
then have a perpetual check and this is
really his last option on board then we
see Queen to d2 check forcing the King
to move King to H 3 and then Queen to h6
and in this position
there was a resignation if you look at
it and this is sometimes tough people
get ahead of themselves and they see
well Queen to h6 he still has a lot of
moves he could play King to g4 he could
come back
- gee - so I'm just gonna go and get
material I'll play pawn down here to see
one I'll get that Queen and this is
gonna be an easy game the problem is
this is actually a drawing game because
that Bishop we talked about here on d3
is blocking these Queens from getting
involved so Queen up here da Czech
forces the King to move and now with
this pawn here on e5 and outpost for the
Queen Queen to f6 forcing the King to
move Hey look Queen down here to h5 only
has one move from here comes back and we
could just keep this party going all day
long and this is a drawing game so if we
come back it's it's like where does
black move well he really needs to come
here to h6 now ding Liron did decide to
go ahead and resign in this position
people always ask what would have
happened after this let's say he tried
the King to g4 ok pawn down here f5
there's two ways to capture one move
would just be with opposite the pawn
takes right here then Queen to h5 check
and then Queen down here c1 check
getting a queen this is all gonna be bad
we're eventually going to end up with
checkmates if you didn't do that let's
say instead of taking with his pawn with
on Passats maybe try something different
maybe Bishop takes here on f5 ok well
that's going to be checkmate right here
that's one option
the also from Queen to h6 decided let's
come back here to g2 then
Queen down here to see one does not have
to worry about that perpetual check that
we talked about because let's say queen
up here to d8 now he can just stop it
with Queen - f8 and then maybe Queen
down here to d4 how does black continue
well Queen d2 check forcing the king to
move and then Queen over here to 8th
getting ready to bring his queen
involved down on this first rank starts
to attack his opponent there's no way
for white to hold on to this so ding
Lyra in this position
decided to go ahead and resign and
although managed call send lost Game one
when he had the white pieces he went on
to win six of the remaining seven game
so you play eight games on day number
three Magnus Carlsen won six of the
remaining seven so just went on it's
hair so for three days straight he's
just been destroying his opponent will
look to continue that tomorrow when they
play twelve games of five-minute blitz
games that should definitely be exciting
but hopefully you guys enjoyed this game
and you've been enjoying the tournament
so far but thanks for watching I'll see
you guys in the next video